all right people we're back in business
that's right i'm live i'm still dave
rubin this is still the reuben report
direct message it's february 28 2022 and
i was off last week i was on vacation
with the family in florida it was
actually the first time that my
family parents brothers sisters spouses
wives husbands all the nieces and
nephews that we had all gotten together
in one place since covid began so over
two years ago this is a family vacation
we try to do uh every president's week
so every february
did not do it last year the last one we
did was two years ago and then basically
the lockdowns kicked in right after that
so it was it was needed and i am rested
and rejuvenated but i do have to say if
i learned one thing this week and i took
a lot of long walks on the beach without
my phone and drank some margaritas ate a
lot of grouper but if i learned one
thing it's that uh you really should try
to do what you love because i actually
did miss being in here i really did and
as we'll get to in a moment
it was a bit of a bizarre week to take
off there's a new war we got that and we
wrapped up covid and the canada thing
ended and a whole bunch of other stuff
and it was like i wanted to be connected
and you know when people see me at the
beach or at a restaurant everyone wants
to talk about politics and i'm trying to
tell people i'm trying not to pay that
much attention but on the other hand i'm
like there's so much going on i gotta
say something
and all that just kind of added up to
like yeah i'm happy to be back in studio
and back with you guys and i'm going to
try my best this is going to be one of
those things i'm really going to try as
we've now entered this new war even
though technically it's not an american
war we're not part of this although you
can't really uh
really see that through if you're
watching the mainstream media it seems
like we're at war right now technically
we are not at war um but i'm gonna
really really do my best to try to give
you as honest information on this thing
this ukraine-russia thing as possible
because it is very very hard to pilfer
any truth out of the mainstream media
and as we've been talking about here for
years at this point they lie about so
many things that now in a case like this
where there is a massive
really game-changing sort of
world-changing war in europe right
it's like who do you believe if if you
believe that the new york times lies
about pretty much everything if you
believe that cnn lies about pretty much
everything and and the rest of them well
then why would they be telling you the
truth on this and that makes it hard for
everybody including a guy like me that
has to for a living sit with some stuff
and go well how can i communicate some
of these ideas to people so that they
don't go crazy so they're they're not
going down the conspiracy rabbit hole so
they're not being just swallowing
propaganda et cetera et cetera so i am
going to do my best regarding all of
that so we'll talk about ukraine and
russia in just a sec but i want to do
one thing real quick before we start
because joe biden's state of the union
addressed is tomorrow night uh joe biden
is the elderly man pretending to be
president of the united states as you
know and uh in advance of his state of
the union you're not gonna believe this
can we pull up the tweet connor
according to breaking 911 congress drops
mask mandate ahead of biden's state of
the union speech on tuesday
mass square is now an individual choice
option the capital attending physician
said
my god is there anything more miraculous
than science and they can wrap up the
vaccine mandates and they can give
choice again to the people and it just
so happens to be
about 36 hours before the guy is going
to give the big speech realizing that
his uh approval is in the tank the
democrats are being obliterated across
the world we got a war and everything
else uh it's just pure nonsense and we
will see
we will see if the good
progressives the science-loving
democrats like aoc and the rest of them
who mostly have not voted in person for
the past two years and they've done
everything by proxy or by computer or
however else they do it we'll see if
they wear masks or if just suddenly
they've agreed we just agree i was
wearing last two days ago not when i'm
on vacation in florida but now i agree
and i'm not going to wear a mask while
i'm in a room with a bunch of these
elderly people and then i just thought
we'd throw you one other video quick uh
before we get to the ukraine stuff and
everything else and i want to do a bit
on canada as well uh this is biden you
may remember this this was late november
early december talking about how we were
all going to die because of covid it's
here now and it's spreading and it's
going to increase
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death for unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospitals they'll soon overwhelm
but
there's good news if you're vaccinated
you have your booster shot you're
protected from severe illness and death
yeah so we never had that winter of
severe illness or death yes omicron did
run around the country and all over the
world and all sorts of people vaccinated
and unvaccinated did get covered i not
vaccinated dave rubin did survive after
three days of leg aches but there was no
severe illness the whole point of
omicron actually was that it was not
severe so the more people that caught it
then we started building up natural
immunity uh there was no severe death it
just didn't happen uh notice that i'll
give you i'll give you an advanced tip
for tomorrow's speech joe's not going to
tell you any numbers related to why two
weeks ago he wanted a vaccine mandate
and tomorrow he won't want one because
they never do right this is what fouchy
always does the well when the numbers
get low enough and what they mean by
that is when it's politically expedient
that's when we'll do the thing that the
rest of us have been screaming about for
two years so there there were no overrun
hospitals this winter none of it they
have fear-mongered and fear-mongered and
fear-mongered and our job people and i'm
ready to continue the job now that i'm
back in studio is to expose their
nonsense all right before we get to uh
ukraine russia some canada stuff and a
whole bunch more i want to talk to you
guys about z stack you know if the last
two years have taught us anything it's
that you must take control of your own
health especially when you hear videos
like that from that elderly gentleman
it's clear that you can't simply rely on
the government or big pharma to protect
you or your family that's where z stack
comes in i've got one right here z-stack
is a specially formulated immune immune
boosting supplement that includes zinc
quesaridin vitamin c and vitamin d
formulated by dr vladzalenko the
world-renowned doctor that president
trump credited with his successful early
treatment protocol and his decision to
take take hcq zstack has been
scientifically formulated is kosher and
gmp certified and is produced right here
in the good old usfa although mass
mandates are being lifted and vaccine
mandates are no longer enforced in
several states and apparently federally
starting today or tomorrow or something
like that viruses are still out there by
taking the stack daily you're
supercharging your immune system z-stack
is formulated to help combat any and all
variants as well as the common cold and
the flu so i encourage you to start
taking it now to stay ahead of any
potential future variants by preparing
your immune system and going about
living your life with nappy novel go to
zstacklife.com
dave today and enter the promo code dave
to get a small discount off your first
order that's zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave and now back to me
all right so i was off last week and
obviously for the two three weeks before
that we went pretty heavy on the trucker
situation up in canada and that there
was a group of people freedom-loving
decent people up in canada who were not
racists or bigots or anti-semites or
transphobes who just wanted canada to
open up they just wanted to go back to
work they wanted their kids back in
school they didn't want everyone masked
they didn't want mandates etc etc they
drove a bunch of trucks across the
country
justin trudeau freaked out he uh did his
emperor palpatine move and got his
emergency powers they were going to
freeze bank accounts of all sorts of
people and then fortunately
because some people stood up and some
people were not afraid to use their
voice and for a week justin trudeau got
trashed in the media and it seemed like
his own country was turning against him
as it should
well you're not going to believe it this
was the crisis of all crises he had to
invoke the emergencies act well he got
rid of it
today
after careful consideration we're ready
to confirm that the situation is no
longer an emergency
therefore the federal government will be
ending the use of the emergencies act
we are confident
that existing laws and bylaws are now
sufficient to keep people safe of course
we'll continue to be there to support
provincial and local authorities if and
when needed
and i want to reassure canadians
law enforcement agencies are prepared to
deal with anyone engaging in unlawful
or dangerous activities
police officers will continue to be
there to protect our streets and
neighborhoods within their jurisdictions
all right so let me be clear about this
although
although justin trudeau did do the right
thing after doing the evil thing and
being exposed for it he is still a very
very bad man you saw
you saw over the course of those 10 days
or so
as he made protests illegal as he
threatened to freeze people's bank
accounts as his government started
looking in to the financial transactions
of private citizens you saw what lies
beneath
his progressive liberal tolerant
nonsense that he constantly spews and
even the tenor with which he talks he
sounds very soft and nice and he loves
his lgbtql
people but he's really just an evil
authoritarian freak so i would like to
applaud all of the people in canada who
stood up who did not break the law who
protested at peacefully as it is their
right in a western nation to protest
your government who had their voices
heard who then got premiers of some of
the provinces to rescind some of the
mandates to start opening up they did it
all right so golf clap for you good
people you did it right i'm glad that we
were able to amplify some of the voices
and some of the stories obviously we did
it here and many other shows did it as
well
and it shows
that individuals can make a difference
if a bunch of individuals had not
decided to do this there is no doubt
that canada would still be in lockdown
there is no doubt that trudeau would
still be figuring out ways he could
silence his people okay so it shows you
have power and that's what they fear
more than anything else we the people
have power i know we the people's in
american phrase but we the people you
the people up in canada you got some
power to and these people should be
credited uh and if any of their bank
accounts were frozen
or any of them were arrested or whatever
it is uh hopefully that will all be
taken back and and and trudeau probably
owes these people reparations for the
fear that he caused i mean imagine
thinking you were going to lose your job
because you showed up to a protest or
that your bank account was going to be
frozen if you gave five dollars to
something that was perfectly legal when
you gave the money and then three days
later the government decides to make it
illegal to give money to these people
and you think you're going to lose your
job or you're not going to be able to
pay your rent or whatever it might be he
is a he is a bad dude
but when good people stand up against
bad dudes guess what guys some good
stuff happens so congratulations again
to everyone in canada and by the way the
fight has just begun right like this
guy's making it very clear oh if you
guys misbehave again and do anything
illegal even though no one did anything
illegal this past time we're going to
come get you and law enforcement's
watching out for you so he's a bad dude
but there there's a little bit of a win
here and this is one of the things that
i try to talk about all the time which
is if we get a win
you know if we if something good happens
if glenn younkin wins in virginia
pushing back critical race theory if the
truckers peacefully protest and then the
end result is that some of these
mandates will be scaled back we got to
acknowledge it we got to sit with it and
go all right it was we the people who
did something good so that is a
beautiful thing justin trudeau i still
don't like you and i will keep coming
after you because you're a bad man a
very very bad man uh justin trudeau is
manscaped though there's no doubt that
this is a guy who manscapes and uh you
know men's below the waist grooming well
let's talk about it for just a moment if
you haven't heard about it yet manscape
offers precision engineered tools for
your family jewels
that's good
they recently launched the ultimate
men's hygiene bundle the performance
package and you can join over 4 million
men worldwide who trust manscaped with
this exclusive offer you'll get 20 off
and free worldwide shipping with my code
ruben at manscape.com
this performance package has it all you
get the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer crop
preserver deodorant for the air down
there crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
all your goodies manscaped has
revolutionized the field of self-care
for men their fourth generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents it's all part
of their advanced
skin safe technology and it's waterproof
and includes a 400k led spotlight in
case you need to get a little more
precise when you're shaving get 20 off
and free shipping with the code ruben at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping at manscaped.com
using code ruben unlock your confidence
and always use the right tools for the
job with manscaped and now back to me
okay so let's get to it let's talk about
russia and ukraine for just a moment i'm
going to caffeinate so i do it right for
you
there we go all right so obviously the
big story last week is that russia led
by vladimir putin has invaded ukraine
okay ukraine is an independent nation
they have largely allied with the west
over the last decade or so and putin for
weeks actually for about the last two
months this was a sort of slow-motion
war right we kept hearing there's going
to be a war one of these days in in
ukraine russia is going to send troops
in and biden kept hinting it too it was
almost as if biden was acting as putin's
press agent well he may go in and we're
thinking about what he's going to do and
he may and if he has to we'll do what he
does all the usual nonsense so i'm going
to try my best
i really mean this i always try this but
i really mean it for this because it's
just such a cluster
f
of misinformation out there uh i'm going
to do my best to lay out sort of a
let's say an unemotional case as to what
really is going on here and then i can
obviously share my opinions on that so
we we looked for a bunch of stuff and
phoenix found this piece from ben
shapiro and obviously ben shapiro he
knows his stuff i think we read it and i
thought it was like a pretty solid
version of just the facts of what's
going on right now so this is from the
daily wire
from ben shapiro so russia has invaded
ukraine the invasion has been a long
time in the making so what drove putin
the answer comes from putin's own mouth
just days ago he gave a militant speech
in which he said ukraine is not just a
neighboring country for us it is an
inalienable part of our own history
culture and spiritual space since time
immemorial the people living in the
southwest of what has historically been
russian land have called themselves
russians the real reason putin is moving
now is threefold first russia has a
major advantage right now natural gas
and oil europe has spent the last decade
destroying its own energy capacity at
the behest of greta thunberg and company
second the west has demonstrated utter
incapacity to challenge putin's prior
predations putin has no reason to think
that any consequences will either long
will be
excuse me will be either long lasting or
significant and on a broader level putin
has watched as the west surrenders to
aggressive dictatorial powers repeatedly
from hong kong in 2020 to afghanistan in
2021 third putin envisions a reimagined
world order he clearly lusts for a
return to russian glory and he sees that
china has oriented itself under xi
jinping toward a similar purpose so let
me back out for just one second so okay
so that that's a basic explanation of
what's going on here using putin's own
words he just believes fundamentally
that ukraine belongs to greater russia
okay right like that's just the sort of
basic idea here now you can believe
uh that that is true or not the
ukrainian people obviously do not
believe that and i believe that they
have a right to defend their own land as
i would argue any people on earth have a
right to do and how you go about doing
that that is where the the devil lies in
the details okay so this was a slow
motion attack for about two weeks where
they kept saying we're going to do it
when are we doing it there's going to be
a troop build up there was all this
weird stuff like is it going to happen
it has to happen and then things sort of
get their own entropy and clearly it was
on the way we all knew it was going to
happen and it was just a matter of when
it was going to happen so first we have
a video compilation of some of the
attacks going on in ukraine by the
russian army
is
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] you you might not
[Music]
okay so the reason i wanted to show you
guys that and i'm sure you're seeing the
clips on twitter or wherever else you go
for this kind of stuff but the reason i
want to show you that little compilation
there was because this is real this is
real stuff you know if you watch
mainstream media it's so much about the
the players involved right this is putin
wants to go in and do this and it seems
almost inhuman that there's no human
level of what's going on there those are
people's houses those are people's
apartments these uh ukraine is a free
sovereign nation that's a member of the
united nations and russia just decided
to go in
for whatever their
reasons are that they believe in this
greater russia russia idea that's what
putin believes in and they just decided
we're going to kill people we're going
to
attack infrastructure we're going to
cause people to flee
right now in ukraine if you're a male
between i believe it's 18 and 61
they're basically drafting you into the
army right now they're handing out
weapons which sort of makes you think
that perhaps
citizens should have weapons it's a good
thing we've got that second amendment
here in the united states um and i also
wanted to mention that on a personal
note of this you know we have a local's
office uh in ukraine i don't want to say
what city it's in but the city is under
attack right now
and i want to give a shout out to six of
our guys that are there mikola maxim
vitale vlad and evgeny um all work
in in one of our offices there uh
they're safe we're in contact the ceo of
locals is in contact with them and we're
trying to figure out what we can do to
help them um and
it's real like this is real stuff these
are people that just
want to
live that did not anticipate that you
know say six months ago oh we'd be
fleeing our homes or we'd be separated
from our families or anything else so
it's uh
there's a human part of this that i just
think we can't forget because we can all
get lost in in the sort of social media
part of it of putin versus biden and all
of that stuff anyway what's what's
particularly interesting uh about all of
this is that the ukrainian president his
name is vladimir zelinski and in a
bizarre twist as i'm sure some of you
have heard already he is a comedian he
is a stand-up comedian he is a jewish
stand-up comedian so this in essence is
like if jerry seinfeld became the
president of the united states that's
sort of what happened here in ukraine
makes you you know it's like all right
pretty good you know why not have a
comedian as president or prime minister
seems good enough well this guy has
proven himself
to be what a true
leader is so we just talked about justin
trudeau a moment ago a guy who wants
power to control people well many
leaders would have fled the country by
now because he knows zelensky that there
is a mark on him right like putin would
gladly take him out if given the
opportunity and perhaps he's just
waiting for the right moment well
zielinski is is not leaving he could
leave he is not leaving he is staying
and fighting here's his first message to
the people of ukraine and to the world
foreign
i want you to really for just one second
think about the bravery this guy there
is no doubt with russian intelligence
they know exactly where zelensky is
there is no doubt simply no doubt that
through a drone strike or whatever other
means or a jet or whatever they got to
do a guy on the ground that they could
take him out and there he is standing
there saying we will defend our land we
will defend our country this is not what
most leaders would do it really is not
what most leaders would do in a
situation like this a situation that
seems so insurmountable right the
ukrainian army is nothing compared to
the russian army but it's not just
zielinski
that is proudly defending his nation
he's got a whole bunch of other
officials that have not fled kiev and
are standing and fighting and making
sure the world knows
president
premier ministers
president tutu
and it could choke you up we are not
going to flee we are going to defend our
independence i mean
that's what it's all about and and to
see leaders doing the right thing it's
it's rare these days now uh we have this
guy joe biden who's president of the
united states and he's been busy with a
lot of different things uh just the
other day he nominated catanji brown
jackson
to be the next supreme court justice as
you know he decided that he would choose
a black woman in the name of diversity
oddly didn't go with a native american
or a trans lesbian or an asian woman or
something black woman got to be a black
woman so while this is all going on
biden gave a little speech and he got a
little crossed up at the end of it i
this is a little heavy-handed but ah i'm
having fun let me pull this out for you
how is
you got it but okay
say presidents can't do much
thank you
presidents can't do much
i mean putin is sitting in a room
laughing right now he is he is drinking
vodka and laughing but okay
i get it it was a little heavy-handed
dave you're right people so now here's
jen saki she is the white house press
secretary as you know i'm not a fan of
jen saki she cannot say anything true
here she is explaining how the biden
administration is actually succeeding
with our policy related to russia and
sanctions there's a report in the new
york times that you guys kept asking
china to help you stop russia from
invading ukraine
and they didn't so
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russia
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions are
going to take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked
what the president has done is he has
built a global coalition
to stand up in the face of president
putin and president putin's aggression
and invasion of ukraine what he has done
is he has rallied the world our eu
european partners even at cost to them
in some capacities to put in place uh
significant sanctions historic sanctions
that would have a a
a enormous impact on the russian
financial side
dave
breathe deep because as she says that
with a straight face that we've put
enormous sanctions powerful sanctions
these are deep sanctions these are
sanctions that'll do a lot
well here's deputy national security
adviser de leit singh talking about
those sanctions
to be clear our sanctions are not
designed to cause any disruption to the
current flow of energy from russia to
the world
i couldn't have just did i just maybe i
didn't hear that right could we get that
one one more time because she said i
thought he was very clear that we're
doing a lot with sanctions and we're
going to stop these people because
they're bad people to be clear our
sanctions are not designed to cause any
disruption to the current flow of energy
from russia to the world
do you realize how bananas that is
sanctions what you do with sanctions is
sanctions are designed so that you don't
have to go
to war so that you don't have to bomb
people so let's say you want another
country to do something let's forget
what it is we don't have to make this
about russia ukraine anything else you
just have some leverage over a country
you want them to do something right
you're the good guys they're the bad
guys you want them to do something but
you say i don't want to bomb these
people and cause all of that damage and
death and all that so you use sanctions
these are these are ways of turning the
levers of economics so that the country
will hopefully do what it is that you
would like
so that's what you do with sanctions but
we are telling them we are quite
literally
telling russia that the sanctions we're
putting in are not going to affect your
energy and not going to affect the
export of your energy and the oil and
all of that stuff
this is a problem so what she says there
what sake
says in essence is all nonsense well
we've put together a big group of people
and we're all going to do a lot of stuff
and you know in about a month a whole
bunch of stuff can happen and peter
ducey at fox news who i often give a lot
of credit to i give him more credit
because he even says do the people of
ukraine have a month do you think
zelensky out there right now with a rag
tag bunch of people who are being handed
weapons as
his citizens are fleeing to get to the
borders and poland's trying to figure
out how many people they can take and
all of this stuff do you think they have
a month while we're
putting in sanctions that actually won't
do much of anything that would be the
equivalent of trying to punish your kid
and saying you know what you you really
did bad you did that bad thing and we're
gonna put you up in your bedroom and you
know yeah there are your ps5s up there
and you're going to get unlimited soda
and pizza and we got a hooker in there
too and some cocaine have fun at it you
know go for it
i'm not a parent yet so that seemed like
what parent would do i don't know i'm
working on it um
these people are just absolutely
ridiculous and now speaking of
ridiculous people i saw this clip this
morning this is from msnbc and msnbc as
i have often described is a mental
institution
that they put on television where people
say completely insane things but they do
it with under the guise of you know
pretending that they know what they're
talking about and i just would like to
just say i am not related to this guy
look at his last name this is the
definition of giving aid and comfort to
the enemy
this is exactly why vladimir putin
misses donald trump so much
because he knew in donald trump he had a
pliable person sitting in the oval
office he knew in donald trump he had a
president of the united states willing
to withhold defensive military equipment
javelins in this case back in 2018 2019
from ukraine
in order to steal the upcoming election
uh donald trump's track record on
vladimir putin is an embarrassment for
the country if donald trump were still
in the white house nato would be in
disarray and vladimir putin would be
driving right through the heart of
europe there is no doubt in my mind or
in anyone in the national security
community's mind that if donald trump
were president he would be saying
exactly what he's saying now and that
would be facilitating this reckless
vile invasion of ukraine
you really have to admire these people
who can get everything wrong and in some
ways have their entire world view
just summed up by what donald trump did
or didn't do everything that that guy
just said reuben even with the same
spelling it's really disappointing i am
not related to joel rubin i am not
related to jennifer rubin i may have to
change my name but it's in all of our
branding at this point it would be very
can we look into it we're going to
create a whole new graphics package
that's going to be a pain in the ass but
these people are ridiculous we had four
years of donald trump now you may not
like donald trump and you may say he was
orange he didn't like the way he tweeted
his hair is a little funny you may not
like any of the things about donald
trump that's very possible but
uh vladimir putin did not attack ukraine
under donald trump do you think that
maybe perhaps had a little something to
do with that donald trump is thought of
as a little erratic we didn't know what
he was going to do maybe we were going
to get into a war that we carried a big
stick he had a lot of bravado and all
that stuff maybe
but
the idea
that that oh god these people
and they put this on msnbc and then
people are watching it and going this is
all donald trump's fault and it's like
donald trump is not even the freaking
president he's not even the president
well donald trump did
go to cpac up in orlando this past
weekend and he talked about russia
ukraine
and joe biden's response take a look
and a major war in europe
may very well erupt that's how they
start exactly what's happening today
this is how they start
joe biden has turned calm into chaos
confidence into incompetence
stability
into anarchy
and security
into catastrophe
the russian attack on ukraine is
appalling
it's an outrage
and an atrocity that should never
have been allowed to occur it never
would have occurred
we are praying for the proud people of
ukraine god blessed them all god
[Music]
all right so let me go back to where i
started the show today i'm going to try
to give you as honest an assessment of
all as possible so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that if donald trump
was president this absolutely would not
have happened i don't know right i don't
think anyone really knows we don't know
the full nature of their relationship
whether putin feared trump more or
whatever else it might be so that's one
piece of this the next piece is that
there's just simply no doubt that a guy
like vladimir putin is looking at the
united states looking at a deeply deeply
unpopular president with extraordinarily
low approval ratings joe biden low 30s
low 30s basically lower than at any
point during trump's presidency despite
the whole media trying to prop him up
all the time looking at all of our
division right now looking at our supply
chain problems looking at the debacle in
afghanistan looking at inflation all of
the stuff and going oh there's a weak
president maybe i have an opportunity
now okay that's not picking sides for me
right like that's just the reality of
what geopolitics is like you look at
leaders and you say oh that leader of
that nation is strong those guys have
some weapons they like to exert their
influence maybe we shouldn't mess with
them maybe we shouldn't be invading
sovereign nations or you might look at a
leader that says oh you can run past our
red lines as obama did in syria or our
our economy is not good here so i'm kind
of weak so we know that that guy is just
sort of not liked and all of that right
so these are the realities of
geopolitics you don't have to know
everything about the inside
uh
every every little in and out of exactly
what's going on in russian ukraine to
understand sort of bigger
worldwide trends and i mean i wrote
about this in my book like strong
leaders and strong countries don't go to
war right you can exert influence in
other ways you can use sanctions
perhaps to get things done but you can't
use sanctions when you actually say that
the sanctions aren't really sanctions
because we're not going to affect the
stuff that really upset you because
anyway let's talk about joy behar for
just a second because this i saw this
clip i was sitting on the beach
why did i open my phone why
i don't know why
but sitting there was a beautiful day
it's getting sun you can see i got a
little color in my face i was drinking a
margarita
i was actually building a sandcastle i'm
getting quite good at the drip castle
with my nieces and nephews i'm building
really incredible stuff anyway something
happened i picked up my phone
i have a text message from somebody you
got to see what joy behar just said you
got to see estimates or 50 000
ukrainians will be dead or wounded and
that this is going to start a
humanitarian crisis a refugee crisis in
europe we're talking about 5 million
people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean it's it's heartbreaking to hear
what is going to happen yeah well i'm
scared of what's going to happen in in
western europe too yeah you know you
just you plan a trip you want to go
there i want to go to italy for four
years i haven't been able to make it
because of of uh the pandemic and now
this you know it's like who's gonna
what's gonna happen there
joy was that real life
joy behar is worried about her italian
vacation in western europe now first off
this is all happening in eastern europe
but she's really just worried about
herself which is just the perfect
perfect progressive
how does this really affect her and her
vacation which would no doubt be at all
the fanciest hotels we had all the
fanciest restaurants and everything it's
so extraordinarily out of touch
it's just
like it's jaw-dropping it's actually
jaw-dropping what she just said there
just
absolutely
incredible joy i know you live in new
york city go down to italy okay it's in
tribeca and it's a big restaurant and
it's a market and they've got wine and
they've got a cheese section you can get
fresh pasta made you can pretend you're
in italy you'll be okay you crazy loon
guys it's monday which means it's meme
monday over at the reuben report locals
community here's the meme that i put up
this morning which was a
perfect blend of what we did on the show
today trudeau jealous another dictator
taking all his press coverage and
there's vlad there you go so we've got a
whole bunch of you guys throwing your
memes in there it's one of my favorite
days of the week monday i get back to
work people put in some funny stuff so
you can join us at ruben
report.locals.com if you want to play
along
and a couple comments from the locals
community pat says every time dave takes
time off some major cataclysm occurs
afghanistan was in last august yeah you
know i don't know like am i just
connected into the system but this is
the point this is actually why and i
mean this for everybody whether whether
you do the sort of news culture stuff
for a living or whatever you do whether
you're an electrician or a plumber or an
accountant taking a little time off of
this stuff is also good because it gives
you fresh eyes to look at all of it and
you know you can think about some of it
without having to react to it constantly
but yes i will be doing off the grid
august this august and lord only knows
what i will come back to anastasia says
where can i go for news on current
events happening in russia and ukraine
you know it's tough this is what i
started the show with and this is what
my challenge will be and i hope that i
will rise to the challenge and it'll be
the challenge of these guys in the room
with me right now that as this unfolds
what the real damage that has happened
in this country beyond covet and masks
and lockdowns and everything else is the
information war that we're in that's
what it is that people do people see the
same exact thing and believe completely
different things or people have catered
news to themselves that they can't see
reality that so many of our pundits are
liars
and propagandists and everything else
and i again i will not sit here and
pretend that i am an expert in eastern
european russian ukrainian relations
right like i'm pretty good on american
politics i know quite a bit about canada
actually can do really well on middle
east stuff as well this is not the part
of the world that is my area of
expertise but i will do my job
i will do the to the best of my ability
uh a job to translate some of this stuff
to you in in a sensible way because you
guys have lives and jobs and things to
do and you want to understand things but
i would guarantee you that over the
course of the next few weeks as this
unfolds if you are the type of person
that wakes up in the morning and has
your coffee while reading the new york
times you're going to find out
information that is quite different if
not 180 degrees different than someone
that reads say a more conservative
leaning outlet or maybe watches tucker
carlson or whatever it is so the daily
wire obviously i think does a really
nice job i'm slightly partial obviously
to the blaze as well but i think they do
a really good job when it comes to just
giving you facts actually the daily the
blaze does a really nice thing where
they break down like here are just the
facts of the story and then they can
have some editorial stuff as well but if
you read the new york times and my dad
god bless him he still subscribes to the
new york times and it was in the condo
in florida and i i mean it's not a great
way to start the day just for the record
but i was reading some of the stories
and it's like it's it's so subtle it's
subtle the way they editorialize
everything so you got to watch out so
i'll do the best i can and if you guys
have any insight into that uh who we
should be reading so that you know we
can sort of translate that information
and give it to you in bite-sized
portions so you can have decent
conversations with your friends and
family about this stuff please do let us
know
zoe says ukraine versus russia is a
democracy against a dictatorship good
against evil this is everyone's war you
know there are international protests
all over the world right now
people supporting ukraine and in essence
yes that's what i started with also
ukraine is a democracy it is a western
democracy they broke away from the
soviet union russia now wants them back
putin wants them back but these people
want to live freely listen to what
zelensky said there they want to live
freely they deserve our support
i would also say they would deserve a
an american leadership that had moral
authority and clarity to to help in a
time like this i don't know that we have
that and by the way i can also
say that you know there's a huge part of
me obviously that has has deep deep
libertarian beliefs and part of me is
also like well you know we've got our
own problems here we've got a fentanyl
problem we've got a border problem we've
got all of the economic problems we've
still got all of the nonsense with
wokism and critical race they're all
like we have so much stuff
that we have to deal with ourselves it's
like how much can we do for the world i
think that's a that's not saying we have
to be isolationist and we should never
do anything and we should have no moral
authority or never use our influence but
i think we can have an honest discussion
about what we can do although if you try
to have that honest discussion then they
say you're you're you're a putin
lover a putin supporter something like
that a putin puppet
guys join us along for the show if you
want we do the live chat there every day
at rubin report.locals.com my full
interview with dennis prager my good
friend and confidante dennis prager is
up on youtube and on rumble and ad free
at rubincourt.logos.com and my interview
this week uh will be with harriet
hageman she is the republican
running against liz cheney in wyoming
it's a really interesting interview i
met her a couple weeks ago at an event
here in miami and i thought i have to
have her on running against liz cheney
trying to sort of restore
sanity to the republican party and and
you know deal with this internal fight
of whether you're going to have these
sort of pet republicans that are loved
by the media say liz cheney or people
who will actually stand up uh for
whatever conservative principles they
have uh that is up already at
rubinport.locals.com and we'll be up on
the youtube and on rumble today all
right people we're back in action here i
will so
tomorrow i mentioned it up top tomorrow
uh the state of the union is at what
time probably about 8 p.m
it's at 9 00 pm eastern we will be live
at 10 p.m eastern with full
coverage i may bring my fake news man
glasses i promise you i'll bring tequila
and i hope you will join us at 10 pm
whenever the elderly gentleman who's
pretending to be president wraps up and
none of them will be wearing masks
because i guess we've moved on from that
thing and it's wartime now so have a
great day everybody and i'll see you
tomorrow